we got the story from timcast.com
McCarthy removes Schiff swalwell from
house intelligence committee quote I'm
committed to returning the house
intelligence committee to one of genuine
honesty and credibility and uh Mike
cernovich posted this video of Kevin
McCarthy just absolutely wrecking the
media explaining how small well there's
an FBI briefing on his association with
a Chinese spy but more importantly Adam
Schiff lied about Russia now Adam Schiff
lied about the hunter Biden laptop
all for political gain and that is why
he is not going to be allowed to get
access to intelligence information in
these committees so Mike servich says
start apologizing because he's he's
going you know he's uh he's bringing the
heat so I'll respect that uh to a
certain degree and say okay you know I
expected macarthy to do something wasn't
sure how far he'd go let's see how far
he does go but we were just talking
about the manipulators the cult how they
lie and the story of with Adam Schiff is
is is fascinating I pulled up an article
from February of 2018 where he said we
have evidence that Donald Trump colluded
with Russia it's just not publicly
available yet
and so these people just say okay that
proves it yeah as if like he just he
says that turns out guess what no they
didn't have any evidence what does it
say uh law makes it halfway around the
earth before the truth gets his shoes on
yeah that's right Churchill yeah yeah
but the you know the the second part of
that I added on was but when the truth
gets to choose on oh boy it gets to
running that's a good one I mean Adam's
not with the internet especially yeah
you know yeah you know because it's like
now you feel lied to now you feel
betrayed so you know you Empower these
people to go out and like want to spread
the truth Goofy on tight you know loyal
to the foil that's what happens but um
it's his business when you talk about
media you're talking about business
they're not really worried about the
welfare of people they're not concerned
with uh what type of radioactive
atmosphere they could create or tension
they just want to fix them with the
clicks they just want to be first yeah
they want to be first they want the
clicks I follow this one account it
tells you every time uh I think it's the
New York Times changes their headlines
or something like that it's a bot oh wow
that's a good one and I just it makes
like amendments and you see it and you
can see how they're optimizing your
headlines for a higher click-through
rate it's called AB testing yeah so what
these news organizations do
they they've always done this back
before the internet the New York Times
and other newspapers I think the New
York Times but newspapers would send out
two different front pages if Donald
Trump was uh working on say a peace deal
with North Korea
the newspapers in New York would say
Trump Sparks outrage by appeasing North
Korean dictator
and then when the paper gets sent to a
rural area a conservative area I would
say Trump receives High Praise from
conservatives over peace negotiations
with North Korea because it's all about
selling the paper
same story different angle different
framing what they started doing on the
internet they called a b testing where
it's not even about region necessarily
anymore it kind of is if you live in New
York when you see the article and click
it the headline will say you know Donald
Trump does backflip you live in Omaha
you click it Donald Trump does front
flip and they change them in real time
because now they see the fluctuations
and they're like we put out the same
story we put it out with five headlines
here's the rate of Click through per
headline this one did the best then
they'll start moving and changing the
headlines in other areas that's crazy
isn't it and and it's and it's framing
too which changes your understanding of
the story right so
timcast.com ran a story a long time ago
that said like Joe Biden criticized for
this thing and I immediately said to the
news team we should not do stories that
are just about someone criticizing Joe
Biden the story should be about what he
did and then we can include reactions so
Joe Biden does backflip not Joe Biden
slammed by conservatives because of
course he's going to get slammed by
cancer no no tell us what's happening
that include the commentary because what
they'll do is you see a story that says
Trump Under Fire for doing backflip and
the average person just hears Trump bad
Trump bad Trump negative everyone's mad
when in reality it could be like under
Fire from two people yeah
if you're if you're talking opinion
pieces I got no qualms no because I do
exactly that yeah I do my opinion
segments and I'll put Trump slam for
this reason because I'm quite literally
opining on my thoughts I'll be like Joe
Biden roasted for doing this thing and
I'll say this is why people are angry
because I'm doing opinion commentary
right but for our straight new stuff I'm
like
just tell us what happened first well I
don't think majority people are even
reading that like they're not clicking
through and seeing the category opinion
op-ed they're not seeing that they're
just seeing the headlines so they're
just taking oh this is news and it comes
from a reputable Source or well I mean
reputable back to the context of the
McCarthy stuff Adam Schiff was was using
his position on the intelligence
committee to claim evidence existed that
was you know confidential that the
American people couldn't see yeah and
then they just had to trust him for it
yeah and he was lying so then you get
journalists who write confirmed evidence
exists Trump clue with Russia and it's
like bro some guy just said that like
you saw the Demar Hamlin thing right
right he's at the the Bills game but
he's wearing a hood and a mask and
glasses and he's waving his arms and you
can't see his face yeah the hollow man
that's right hollow man yeah TMZ says we
called and confirmed because someone
told us it was actually him I'm like but
they don't even say who they call right
you didn't confirm anything did you call
his mom he calls agent he called the
actual team I mean this is the Escalade
right right that's what I think but it's
an escalation into making it all seem
like oh it's common knowledge it's
common knowledge colluded with Russia
and then you can stop questioning it
please don't ask us where our sources
are yeah that's creepy when Mueller came
out and was like nah what did what did
Schiff and the rest of the Democrats
start saying what no no no no no he said
Trump's not exonerated yes and I'm like
because you don't exonerate people you
have to prove he did it not that he
didn't do it yeah but just like that
shift's been doing it for as long as
I've been following everything remember
the bombshell witness that they had to
keep and witness protection for you know
about Trump nobody ever found out who
that was yeah and they let him do it or
do that he always had some kind of
bombshell or kind of some kind of
Smoking Gun that he could never deliver
on but the mainstream media backed him
they're doing it now the Washington Post
wrote an article defending swalwell and
defending Adam Schiff and I'll give
swallow credit especially because you
know we had Matt Gates on him at this
point he was like look the Fang Fang
thing was well before he was in Congress
so you know I have questions about that
but I'll say this if Kevin McCarthy says
the FBI briefed him saying we have
concerns about this then I'll be like I
don't trust the FBI but if they're going
after a Democrat there must be something
there was this the The Briefing no the
when when he said yes
when he said at evidence with Russian
collusion what year was it oh 2018. I
mean but come on Adam Schiff said it
every single day non-stop the entire
time that Trump was in office they were
they were doing it so yeah well he was
clever too he was clever he'd say things
like
he was a I pulled up one interview from
CBS and they're like is there direct
evidence of collusion and Hugo we have
conversations that have been released to
the public between Donald Trump and
Russian Banks and the Moscow deals that
is direct evidence of collusion and it's
like you see the game he's playing is
he's saying a thing exists that's
already in the public therefore it's
evidence and it's true but you don't
know the thing he's actually referencing
well let me let me let me set the idea
let me set this on fire you ready keep
an eye on the chat
shift did us a favor
you gotta let that one sit let the chat
okay oh my God what is he talking about
build suspense I love it yeah now
everybody's angry now what's the counter
um
Trump didn't win imagine what this
country would look like if Trump ran and
won
I'm gonna tell you right now
this country if Trump would have won
would have been on fire on Flames antifa
would have been everywhere just setting
things up I that's what I feel I feel
like a whole bunch of remember the
summer of black lives matter summer
velocity the summer I love oh man we
didn't have four years of love
that's tough it's tough because there's
there there's there's some truth there
that uh we don't want violence we don't
want destruction and we don't want death
no we don't but at the same time does
that mean you let corrupt people take
over and and run this country into the
ground so you know what we're dealing
with now it was the hard fall or the
slow fall and the question is do you rip
the Bandit off as fast as you can get it
over with yeah or do you slowly peel it
pulling every little hair along with it
yeah that's a tough question and the
question is this if Donald Trump won an
antifa on the far left did go nuts would
Trump have then with his final term gone
in and finally started arresting these
people charging them in mass and
shutting it all down I actually think
that probably would happen I think
Donald Trump was scared to go after
antifung the far left in the Summer of
Love because he was going to run for
reelection he was like they will call me
a fascist it will be weaponized against
me so the strategy I think Trump took
was hey man you live in Portland you
voted for this they can deal with it but
in term two he's like I'm not getting
reelected again send in the Ascend in
the Army National Guard whatever right
yeah you go hard you go hard your last
term you know what I mean yeah do you
think that he had that in him yeah I do
yeah I think he I think I think he had
it in him you know what I mean I think
he had it in him if not he had a hell of
a poker face he'd have bluffed out he
would have bluffed it yeah he'd have
Bluff the heck out of it and they would
have been scared they'd have back right
up they'd back right up I guarantee it I
wonder I question
because of the way that he behaved
I question whether he actually did have
the resolve that his that his that his
bull you know his his uh bolstering
scene yeah you know he because he didn't
he wasn't an authoritarian the way that
that a lot of people said that he was
there was a lot of times where there
were a lot of people saying look you
should send the the National Guard in
especially when they were the the people
were rioting in Portland at the uh
um at the courthouse and stuff was that
Seattle or Portland I think it was
Portland yeah it was Portland there's
you know and I think that he was no I
think he was nervous about actually
doing that I think that after the the
issues in DC when he had to be run to
the to the bunker and the way that the
press and media responded to an actual
attack on the White House the way they
responded they were trying to Olympus
his fall in the White House yeah I think
that he was concerned with with using
too much force because he wasn't going
to get any he was going to get he knew
he was gonna get crushed and Donald
Trump wanted to be liked more than
anything in the world this is this is
the problem that Trump had he's not
Machiavellian you know when the 529
Insurrection happened antifa shows up
the White House and tried to Olympus was
Olympus Has Fallen Olympus Has Fallen
yeah the rod Butler movies when uh so I
say this all the time
if Donald Trump ordered the law
enforcement to stand down
and antifa then ripped the fences down
and torched Saint John's Church
it would have shifted The Narrative of
this country 180 degrees he would be in
the bunker he would come out the next
day to a destroyed historic American
Church the White House being rampaged by
far left extremists and he would say the
attack on this country by the far left
extremists is unprecedented not since
the 1890s or whatever 1880s has the
White House been attacked before has a
historical church been set aflame he
could say something like
the fear that we had as good stewards of
the Constitution was that to send out
law enforcement to shut down what was
what had begun as a peaceful protest
would be an affront to the rights of
every American citizen if only we had
known the violence the hatred and the
danger that was far left extremism then
we would have taken action but we
believed in the American people and the
right to protest and unfortunately the
the extremists on the far left and
antifa exploited that to destroy iconic
American you know images you don't you
don't think the leftist media would have
spun that
you can't spend St John's Church torched
and Raised To The Ground by the far left
the problem is
how did you spin it it's the left I'll
put nothing past them maybe like he
deserved that and the church
and you're right yes but think about the
Suburban housewife who's seeing
smoldering ruins from far left
extremists is that the target demo
you're saying of this speech we're not
trying to convince the far left in the
corporate press to vote for anybody yeah
see but the thing is Donald Trump is not
Machiavellian he said hey they're
they're trying to burn a church down
stop them quick and they did but but
would that Mom get the Donald Trump
speech or would she get a contorted
version of that from far left is Media
you're you're not wrong about that yeah
but I'm talking about weight right okay
when when far left extremists set fire
to St John's Church and they did yeah
set fire to a guard post the White House
and and tore down the barricades
injuring I think like a hundred plus Law
Enforcement Officers Trump shut down and
the narrative from the media was Trump
attacks peaceful president so you're
saying you should have let it go let it
happen I'm not saying he should have
you're saying if he did the
Machiavellian manipulative you know uh
evil way to deal with it and that's what
I'm saying I'm saying Trump's not an
evil guy right Trump said hey they're
trying to hurt people and burn this
thing now we better stop them yeah the
media spun that against them yeah what
I'm saying is wait if antifa goes and
antifa set fire to Saint John's Church
and the media defended them yeah now
what would happen if the church was
raised to the ground it would be a lot
harder to defend them I see what you're
saying yeah that whole oh you know
mostly peaceful where everything burning
in the background or hit a lot harder
when you got a historic church in rubble
in rubble you know versus a church that
almost went down and you got Trump in
front of it holding his Bible right
where they spawn it like oh he had his
Bible upside down I'll tell you what
they do the left would come out and say
the failure of Donald Trump's
Administration to stop the violence is
shocking how could he let this happen
and then Trump could come out and say
you're absolutely right we should have
gone harder and used the military and
the National Guard to stop the violent
far-left extremists but we didn't want
to hurt our fellow Americans but I
confess I was wrong to try and be
peaceful and and maintain the peace it
backfired Tim you you'd make a good
press secretary you're about to say
Trump we should have had you writing his
speeches bro oh Michael Mouse will make
a good press secretary can we do iro
live from the White House Press Room
every night when Trump gets reelected
you know this is the crazy thing to me
because like you look at January 6th
yeah January 6th is exactly what I'm
talking about okay where were the police
right why is there a video of a guy
walking up to cops saying please stop
them look he's pointing to the people
walking what are you doing and the cops
are like nope why are there cops on
video opening the doors and letting
people in and then the Democrats saying
oh no we were attacked it's an
Insurrection and they ran that narrative
for a year and they just started an
investigation they impeached Trump
because of it that's what I'm saying I'm
saying Trump didn't have the the moral
failings to do what Democrats did yeah
because yeah January that day in January
they didn't so he allegedly he asked for
10 000 troops for Guardsmen to be there
yeah allegedly allegedly Nancy Pelosi
said no thank you we don't want the
Optics of that yeah
I think she want the opposite of that
because she got the Optics that she
wanted yup yeah far right extremists
and think think about what happened if I
tell you if on 529 Donald Trump start
was rushed into the Into the Bunker
under under the White House he was and
if he said listen the last thing we want
is a dead protester on the news stand
down and then the protesters ransacked
everything yeah the D Trump would have
been been reelected guaranteed and then
he was at the doj after all of the far
left just like they're doing the January
six people he'd be going after and
rooting out far left cult members and
violent extremists instead what do we
get right now in Atlanta
far left extremists are for out of state
crossing state lines with semi-automatic
weapons occupying a forest shooting cops
and putting them in the hospital calling
for the assassination of police and then
ransacking downtown Atlanta so burning
people's homes and torching a guy's
vehicle that's all happening it's not
stopping it keeps going and we were
surprised
you mean there was an autonomous Zone in
Georgia for the past two years or
whatever and they're burning houses to
the ground and vehicles and one guy shot
a cop yep and the media is protecting
them uh so I'm just over here doing
Italian counting up all the grifters
that we're going I made for the grifties
go to grifties.com nominate your
favorite grifter I see what's the dude's
name from faza that was on the date
Grifton trying to grift his job on a
date Griffin Trish Walker Tristan Jordan
Tristan Jordan Tristan Walker yeah we
got to nominate him somebody go to
different.com I've got nominate him
what's this guy's name
um
we gotta nominate him nominee
yeah because because look a lot of
people will say like they'll be like for
the Griffey it's got to be you know uh
Stephen Crowder or janky Euchre or Tim
Poole it's like I get that you don't
like the commentators but Adam Schiff
yeah as a politician that's a good one a
lot of people mix up the fancy Pelosi a
lot of people mix up the meaning of the
word Griff though because like a lot of
people think that like they just someone
they don't like is a grifter it's like
they'll use that term interchangeably
and like grifting is a it's a very loose
term well we use it you know the the
there's a uh if you watch the grifties
tomorrow grifties.com you'll see it we
have a different definition that we like
to go with but what we like to say is
Loosely there's a light side in this
dark side if somebody is taken away from
the Griffin somebody like you know we be
Grifton we Griffin right now yeah I mean
we grifted off a temple shout out to Tim
cast iron you know everybody's grifting
to some level it's just more like what
are your intentions what's your end game
what are you doing with this all are you
trying to push inoculations on people or
are you trying to free money lines right
sure but at the end of the day
everybody's got a grift right but you're
right sometimes people use the word you
just say I don't like this person he's a
griffin it's just like but it sort of
implies like conning someone you know
what I mean yeah selling them snake oil
yes that's always been my understanding
of it yeah someone that it's like a
sellout an opportunist like they see
something they jump on the message right
like they don't know if they believe I
mean my prime example this is AOC when
she took those pictures crying at the
border and that's the darkness
that's the dark side
you know what I mean you guys phenomenal
you got to do like little montage videos
where it's like the top ten and it's
like Alexandria ocasio-cortez and it
shows like a slow-moving photo and then
it shows her like crying at the border
and it shows her on the phone going
where is she where is she it's playing
like you know orchestral music
she made that story up it was fake it
was fake yeah now that is grifting right
there the question look you gotta you
got to be a special kind of look I I
would not want to play AOC in poker
because she well actually I'll take that
back I can see through her Bluffs but
she would do really really well
bald-faced lie when she's like they come
to my door and bang and I'm hiding in
the bathroom and I hear where is she
it's like yo that happened an hour
before the the building was even
breached so before anybody entered the
building someone knocks on her door and
she's hiding in the bathroom get Addy
she made that up you know it was a cop
looking forward to evacuate the building
she made it up you know she'd be
grateful James will keep Spa programs
but she's you know I say she'd be good
at poker's because she can lie to your
face yeah without with without twitching
without with no tell you'd be like
because she feels like her lies are
Justified I'm obviously I've never met
her I don't know but like there are some
people who feel as though like they are
entitled to lie like their means are so
honorable that they don't don't feel
remorse like people who Flinch when they
lie or give some tell like they feel on
some level guilty about I don't think
they believe that they're lying well
that's true too I really think that
there are people that there are people
like narcissistic yeah it's Saul
alinsky's rules for radical yes right
it's like yeah I might be lying but I'm
doing it for good yeah it's what it's
what is the goal yeah that's in mind and
justifies the means what's that mean
where they have the woman crying with
the snap bubbles coming out say women
can lie this hard I mean people can cry
it's hard and still be lying
they commit I don't know what to tell
you yes it is what it is I mean think
about that with like Nancy feels like if
it's true that she had the chance to
have 10 000 National Guards members at
the Capitol that day and she was like no
we don't need them like I spent uh I was
at opening Arguments for Enrique tario
in the proud voice trial and there are
the federal government was like yeah we
have fbm
foreigners be like okay they should
explain why there was no law enforcement
if you think this this was a planned
Insurrection where was everybody if you
guys knew you didn't defend anything I
mean it just becomes to the point where
you're like is Nancy Pelosi grifting for
this long-term play at the White House
like it's I think this is what puts
Americans off of politics right you want
to believe in The Honorable but you're
shown time and time again that people
operate for their own good like even the
Pfizer video the guy is saying like well
we could make money off of this this
could be good for us turn around and
tell you that Donald Trump did a
passenger 57 in the back of the limo
trying to take out some Secret Service
agents well real quick let me get my
grift on because I'm getting news right
now that my camera's a little dark
somebody said my light isn't right so I
just want to chat help me out does does
Temple have racist cameras does he have
those what is it remember HP like their
cameras wouldn't focus on black people
that's true oh they did that they did
that lighting they there was like a
campaign they did where they're like our
new cameras for all skin tones and yeah
a bunch of black people yeah I didn't
know I just want to make sure chat let
let Serge no let's surge know if my
camera's good I gotta look good man
griffy's tomorrow well it's you're
wearing a black shirt with a black
backdrop oh that's what it is yeah oh
man you always got to bring the race
grift up man cut it out listen I'm a
black supremacist damn it one time we
were uh doing a show and Tim was like
you're too white you're throwing off the
color balance in here I don't know so
maybe it's just like any extreme part of
the skin tone well alcohol like that
Uncle hotep's like white man
who doesn't
I don't know
nobody on the planet just for the record
nobody in the planet hates black people
more than Uncle Hotel oh my gosh he's
here hi Uncle tip
the black the black white supremacist
I've been following Uncle hotep for a
lot of years have you oh yeah oh yeah I
followed him before I followed you
yeah you know you know what's up man
that's terrible I put you on him that's
the question I don't I don't know I
followed him on YouTube I watch his
YouTube channel
um but I'm I'm not sure exactly why do
you like this guy because he makes me
laugh he's funny I'm honest down the per
down the Earth I'm a black man from
extra Pennsylvania
just a black man from exit Pennsylvania
he's a grifter that's what he is Yo Tim
your invitations are spot on man did you
practice that man which one which
imitation both of them are pretty good
pretty good what'd he do he did Trump
and he did uh Trump was not a real
impersonation that was you had it for a
couple the first couple sends you had it
yeah Trump's actually I can't do Trump
at all so I just do like a little bit of
the like he talks in a very weird way
the fouchy thing is I'm actually trying
to do cartoon versions of them okay so
like the fouchy voice that I do is
intended to be an over-the-top
exaggerated version of fauci you don't
need to be wearing two masks so it's
like it's gruffer it's you know and then
Nancy Pelosi when I do her I over
emphasize her teeth she talks like this
is Donald Trump it's the worst man in
this country
that's my Nancy Pelosi so it's like it's
it's kind of cartoony I feel like you
need more lip smacking in the Pelosi
I bet if I actually tried and like
actually practiced I probably could do a
bunch of really good ones absolutely
yeah yeah but I was the voice of fauci
for Freedom tunes for a while that was
that was fun oh that's dope but then
when Fati was out of the news Sheamus
didn't need me on the show anymore so I
just yeah the classic grifter Sheamus
we did we did a bit where uh you guys
saw the story that said if you're not
vaccinated you're more likely to get in
a car accident do you see that one let's
talk about Grifton man but so Sheamus
did a bit where fauci's snipping car
breaks
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time